this is Neill Blomkamp stepping up his
game last time he tackled healthcare
this time he tackles humanity maybe
geppi so chappies written and directed
by Neill Blomkamp this guy did district
9 he did Elysium now he does chappie
he's gonna do alien which I'm still
excited about despite champion to win
the world of chappie ultimately the
police force or a bunch of robots think
like a robot but instead of robots that
you know like do your house chores and
[ __ ] they're cops and Dev Patel is the
one who made these robots so he's like
oh I'm gonna make one with actual
artificial intelligence so he makes
chappie and it's like yeah he's gonna
hang out with Deb Patel and he's gonna
become more human he saw the scene in
the trailer where chappies watching
he-man you know when he's miming raising
the sword you're like eyes gonna get all
of his moral structure from cartoons
like we didn't I get that it's awesome
he's gonna save humanity somehow mm-hmm
I'm sorry to say guys the trailer left
out one very important thing chappies
actually about this artificial
intelligence robot that gets created and
then hangs out with these criminal drug
dealers and gets manipulated to be a
criminal then that happens for about an
hour and a half and Hugh Jackman gets
his day in the Sun than the movie end
was really bummer ultimately chappie
gets dropped off with this crew that you
don't give a [ __ ] about played by bad
actors from a band
here's watching him you're like I want
all of you to die cuz you're all dicks
you never side with these people because
these are criminals who are corrupting a
youth they beat it over your head like
chappies like a kid jab he's like a kid
all right well it's just trying to be an
[ __ ] chappies never an [ __ ] he
just thinks that it's normal to do some
of this [ __ ] and in that the movie does
a really good job at making you see that
this robot this sentient being is
actually being manipulated and you feel
for him you're like oh man get out of
that situation doesn't change the fact
that chappie sees this dude as his dad
and the woman as his mom and you're like
nah chappie just leave them I don't like
them I don't like them in the movie I
don't like what they're doing I just the
movie just feels worse with them in it
and even by the end of this movie these
[ __ ] are unrepentant for corrupting
this child mind that is the sentient
being that is chappie but you're
supposed to feel for them like Oh
and I feel bad for you guys and all the
trials you're having right now there's
just a lesser of two evils out there
it's like a rival gang war and these
just happened to be [ __ ] that
aren't quite as bad as the other
[ __ ] the movie would have been
better if chappie was hanging out with
his maker and he was getting his moral
fiber from his maker and you know
watching he-man cartoons but his maker
would be like chappie we have to be good
we have to not use violence because we
have to be good people you have to show
us what it is to be human it would have
been a great message about humanity then
things that there get worse and chappies
like things are bad but you got to fight
it you got to fight fire with fire
sometimes it would have been like that
scene in Man of Steel when Zod's like
yeah you know like the laser the heat
visions going towards the family and
Superman's like I either kill this guy
or that family gets wiped out and that
was a moral dilemma he was inch happy
could have been in these moral dilemmas
it never really hit you because he's
never really conflicted he's just
manipulated until he's like wait that's
stupid there's not a lot of friction
there because he wasn't taught to be
this good and then he wants to protect
people who were this good but to do that
he kind of has to be less than what he
was taught to be he was taught to be an
[ __ ] and he's like well no brainer
you can be better all right done I mean
the last half-hour this movie was pretty
exciting and deserves that Hugh Jackman
gets his huge machine that's from
Robocop 1 it comes down he has to fight
chappie that was cool and all that
doesn't make up for the rest of the
movie you need everything to lead up to
that to bring relevance to that you
can't just like have a boring ass movie
that's really choppy there's no real
message in all the wasted potential in
the world didn't have one action scene
have everyone be like oh it's cool yeah
and I'm questioning at all it's
perfectly fine now
I love Charlotte oak hopefully as
chappie he's the thing I loved if chappy
could save this movie he would he's
lovable you feel for him when he's
getting hurt you want to slap him in the
head and be like dude they're playing
you stop you want to protect him and if
the movie was going for that that's
great I'm just saying that should have
been one element of the movie the movie
should have had more structure to it I
walked out of the movie just feeling
like a movie about an artificial
intelligence by Neill Blomkamp about
this computer nerd with a huge heart who
creates a robot with a huge heart in a
shitty world I had a lot more to it it
could have had much more of those iron
giant fields so when chappies hanging
out with characters not only do you not
like but you just don't care about for
most of the movie that's a problem in
the end chappie as a movie
not gonna remember it in t-minus a
couple days yep already forgot I got to
update that picture pictures like four
years old I just don't have a watch
anymore I need to get a watch right so
chappy have you seen it what did you
think about it really interested to know
this one whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more